gastroesophageal reflux is a condition
where the contents of your stomach
reflux or leak back into your esophagus
acid in the stomach contents irritates
your esophagus this can cause a painful
burning feeling in your chest called
heartburn or acid indigestion
if it happens more than twice a week for
a few weeks
you may have gastroesophageal reflux
disease or gerd
treatment options for gerd include
lifestyle changes medications
and surgical procedures
making lifestyle changes can help you
control gerd such as losing weight if
you're overweight
eating smaller meals
avoiding certain foods and drinks such
as coffee alcohol chocolate and fatty or
greasy foods
staying upright for three hours after
meals
[Music]
avoiding eating two to three hours
before going to bed
wearing loose fitting clothes around
your waist to avoid squeezing your
stomach which can push acid up into your
esophagus
and quitting smoking if you smoke
there are several types of medications
that can help control your symptoms
antacids help relieve heartburn by
neutralizing the stomach acid that
causes it
h2 blockers and proton pump inhibitors
relieve symptoms by reducing the amount
of acid produced in your stomach
proton pump inhibitors or ppis
also help heal damage to your esophagus
caused by reflux
prokinetics can help your stomach empty
faster so that its contents don't back
up into your esophagus
you may need a combination of these
medicines to control your symptoms
if lifestyle changes and medication
aren't working or if you have a hiatal
hernia your health care provider may
advise a surgical procedure called
funduplication
a hiatal hernia is a condition where
part of your stomach bulges up through
your diaphragm
during the procedure if you have a
hiatal hernia your surgeon will move
your stomach back to its proper place
then your surgeon may tighten the
opening in your diaphragm with stitches
to prevent your stomach from bulging up
through it
next the upper part of your stomach will
be wrapped around your lower esophagus
it will be held there with stitches this
helps prevent stomach contents from
leaking back into your esophagus
to find out more about treatments for
gastroesophageal reflux disease talk to
your healthcare provider
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or nml where
you can download this animation and
thousands of medical images and videos
created by nucleus medical media to
apply for a free 30-day trial click on
the link in the description
you